The person who's writing drew me into the civil war and I confess
was Bruce Catton.
If any of you ever read any of Bruce Catton?
Ah,
it's a dwindling number in the 21st century,
but when I was growing up,
Bruce Catton was the great narrative,
popular historian or popular narrative historian of the civil war.
He wrote some seven books or so from the late 1950 [inaudible] through the 1960s
into the 70s he wrote them around the time of the civil war centennial.
He was not an academic historian.
He was a journalist and a former war correspondent and the Second World War,
and the man had a beautiful sense of narrative.
This is,
and from his book,
Terrible Swift Sword,
which is 1862 the year of 1862 of the civil war.
He is trying by,
he's trying to capture the situation,
the strategic situation,
the emotional,
centrum,
sentimental situation,
the mood of already war,
weary America.
A little more than a year into this thing,
which is where we're going to go a little bit further in a moment.
He's talking though essentially about the most important argument I think we can
make about that first year,
year and a half into the second year of the war.
Both sides wanted a limited war.
Remember that and the confederate side,
they just wanted to fight long enough to make the north or the federal
government acknowledged their independence.
The longer the thing went on,
the more dangerous it was.
Of course,
for the confederacy.
They were outmanned outnumbered
lesser resources,
et Cetera.
On the northern side,
it was the state of policy of the Lincoln administration to keep this a limited
war and a great deal more on this next week when we deal with the emancipation
story,
the whole idea again for Lincoln was to keep this from becoming as he put it,
a remorseless revolutionary struggle.
That is exactly what it had become by the summer of 1862 and here is catton's
description.
I can't do it better.
There was no ability in the idea that there ought to be a peace without victory.
You had an August,
or excuse me,
by August of 1862 America's tragedy was that it was caught between the madness
of going on with the war and the human impossibility of stopping it.
Succession had been a direct result of the outcome of the election of 1860 to
restore the status quo would be to assume that either the north or the south had
had a great change of heart,
that the north would not again go republican or that the South would quietly
acquiesce if it did.
Neither Mr Lincoln nor Mr. Davis was going to assume anything of the kind.
Each man was fighting for a dreadful simplicity.
Neither one could describe a solution acceptable to him without describing
something wholly unacceptable to the other.
Neither man could accept anything less than complete victory without admitting
complete defeat.
Both sides that heard the trumpet that could never call retreat.
The peacemakers could not be heard until the terrible swift sword had been.
She used,
but the scabbard had been thrown away and now the confederacy was carrying the
war into the enemy's country.
Well,
never call retreat is of course a very war like language.
But,
uh,
this was an awful and horrible war.
Okay.
Now Lincoln of course,
and you've read now some documents on this and if you started to watch the Ken
Burns film series,
which by the way is now up on the classes server,
excuse me,
it is up on the classes server and if,
well,
no,
it's up on syndics,
but as Sam Shaffer,
just inform me,
if you go to the classes server,
there is a message and what's a carbon or information and under announcements
that tells you exactly again how to use the URL.
If any of you are already tapped in and uh huh.
Okay.
Make sure your watch episodes two and three through the one entitled for ever
free,
you know,
maybe bar this weekend,
certainly by the beginning of next week.
Uh,
at any rate in that film series,
you'll see that Burns chose to make George being McClellan,
a kind of comic relief.
His vanity,
his arrogance is subordination is almost incredible.
Uh,
if complex hatred of Abraham Lincoln,
Edwin Stanton,
and all the leadership for the federal government that he was commanding the
army for.
Lincoln wanted a strategy in the wake of Bull,
run the disaster at bull run that summer in July,
he puts Mcclellan in charge of the army of the Potomac,
as I said the other day,
Carl,
and takes them into huge encampments all around Washington DC and began in
August,
September,
October and through the fall to drill this army,
train it,
and they came to loving that is all these green young soldier boys from all over
the north.
And then we're arriving now and a whole new regiments week after week after
week,
all formed and local communities across the north.
Okay.
The vast,
vast,
vast majority of them had never showed her in any kind of musket in their lives
except possibly in a local militia.
And only a tiny percentage of them had ever been in a militia.
They actually grew to kind of love McMullen at first because he helped great
parades.
Okay,
great parades.
You made a marsh like hell and train like hell and learn how to march sideways
and forward and backward in retreat and do all that stuff.
The man,
when he held a parade,
it was cool.
They also hadn't seen any war yet.
He didn't move the army like I want them to move at that fall,
go back into Virginia,
go find that confederate army again,
find it on the right ground somewhere,
attack it in the war.
Uh,
not going to happen.
This young,
35 year old,
uh,
general,
um,
was a very cautious soul who would've thought that I would be called up to save
my country,
seven McLeod.
And we have those amazing letters.
He kept writing to his wife over and over and over.
I am called to save my country is buffoons in Washington.
Don't know what they're doing.
Stanton is an idiot.
And at one point he called Lincoln a baboo.
Hmm.
No,
it actually got into the public.
Okay.
He was also make no mistake and it's very important,
especially when we get into 62,
he was a pro slavery Democrat.
He was the farthest thing you could imagine in the union army from an
abolitionist McClellan wanted nothing to do with a remorseless revolutionary
struggle.
He did not want to move huge armies into the Virginia or into the south,
into densely populated slave areas because he did not want to destroy slavery.
He saw that as a revolution.
No Army could somehow control.
He even wrote that fall to a democratic congressman and said,
you must help me help me dodge the nigger,
which the way he put it,
by January Lincoln was impatient to say the least.
Mcclellan caught typhoid fever and was really quite sick for most of a month and
refuse to even answer Lincoln's messages at times.
This is the president of United States is commander in chief is sending him
messages,
couriers and for days McAllen wouldn't have an answer him.
And then there's the famous message that Lincoln sends in February I believe,
of 62 sends a message to Cologne and says,
uh,
general,
if you're not going to use your army,
my Thai borrow it.
Let's move out West.
It was the war is going to break out all over the west whether anybody wanted it
to or not,
whether anybody planned it or
I'll get the outline back up there in case you didn't.
Sorry.
Good to see it.
Uh Huh.
I don't know if you can see all of this in the back row,
but I hope you can see enough to understand that what we have here is the region
of Alabama,
Mississippi,
Tennessee,
Kentucky,
and over into Missouri,
Arkansas and so on.
The war broke out in the West is essentially a river war,
a river war for the
the Tennessee in the Cumberland rivers in Tennessee.
Now you only need to look at a map and with one eye open to understand how
important Tennessee would be in this war if Kentucky has still not seceded from
the union and officially will not,
and if Kentucky remains any kind of buffer for the union,
Tennessee is where the war is going to be fought in the west.
Certainly at first,
and it surely was
now
at first,
the war in the West was essentially fought with gunboats little iron clad
gunboats and armies on the land.
But the first major conflicts in the west were to try to hold on the side of the
confederacy and to take on the,
um,
the northern side to Ford's one called Fort Donaldson,
I want to call Ford Henry one on the Cumberland one,
the Tennessee river.
These rivers were terribly important for transportation.
Now,
especially military transportation.
They flowed down to Nashville,
one of them,
the other flowed southward and then into northern Georgia.
These rivers would be invasion corridors that feel like invasion paths for the
northern armies.
They were extremely important for supply and transportation for the south,
and hence these relatively small forts.
That guard of these two rivers suddenly became the focal point in February,
uh,
by,
by February,
1862,
the union forces that would attack Fort Henry first and then Fort Donaldson were
commanded by a young only in his early forties,
a general who had been promoted rapidly from colonel named Ulysses s grant.
Now grant,
as many of you may know,
uh,
well,
grant has had a huge revival in scholarship in the last oh two decades.
He was for a long time,
all but forgotten in American history,
partly because his presidency was so awful,
and we'll deal with that later on in the course or in some ways so awful.
He got miserably depressed and took to drinking.
That part's true.
When he was stationed way out in California in the late 1850s,
uh,
he was a bit of a drunk in those years and he resigned from the army.
He had been a veteran of the Mexican war decorated.
We quit the army,
bored,
depressed,
and he went back to Illinois.
Is Home,
well,
born in Ohio,
but he went back to Illinois and he was working as the story goes,
it's not a legend in his brother's leather shop and Galena,
Illinois.
When the civil war broke out,
and because he was a west point graduate and the only one around,
they named him colonel and he led the regiment that was formed from that area of
North West Illinois and off to war.
Wouldn't.
Ulysses grant.
Ulysses grant is a classic example and I want to,
I want to give you an illustration of this is a classic example of an American,
an American male for whom most of the rest of life business profession except
for horseback riding,
and he was a hell of a horseman.
Almost everything else in his life had been a failure or near failure or simply
boring.
He'd grown up on farms,
but he hated farming.
He's a classic example of how sometimes war,
tragically or unfortunately can make a person.
We're not for the American civil war.
You'd have never heard of Ulysses s grant.
Okay.
This is bill McPhee,
Lee's description,
William McFeely,
who was written the finest biography of grant,
I think still ever done,
although there've been many since
he's describing grants,
a situation and Galena and how bored he was depressed he was and so on.
And then McFeely rights
war,
the ordinary man's escape from the ordinary.
It was a way out of a leather store and for some men it is much more than that.
It is the fulfillment that the world will yield and no other manner.
For these men wore appears as a refutation of evil,
whether it be the evil of Hitler's threat to mark blocks France or the slave
holders,
threat to throws America or less exalted,
but no less real.
The evil of personal hollowness war for a man like Ulysses grant was the only
situation in which he could truly connect to his country and countrymen and be
at one with them and his self himself.
Grant did not like the vain glory of victory or the drama of high strategy or
the blood of battle,
and he did not think of all wars worth fighting,
that all was worth fighting.
Yet some essential part of his being was broadened to play only in War II.
Never celebrated this fact,
but neither did he deny it.
He knew it was true only in war and possibly at the end of his life in writing
about the war and what would be the greatest memoir of this war.
Did he find the completeness of experience that when engaged in it so intensely
moved in?
Yeah.
Well,
grandma was a soldier
and not unlike Robert E.
Lee.
He did enjoy the spirit of battle.
I don't know if there's any doubt about that.
And he moved down these forts.
First Fort Henry [inaudible] February six with about 15,000 men on land and a
bunch of slow,
cumbersome gunboats.
Fort Henry was not well defended and basically just surrendered a week later on
the other river,
the Cumberland,
okay.
Fort Donaldson was shelled into submission by artillery.
This was the second week of February,
1862 and grant famously demanded and unconditional surrender from generals,
Simon Boulevard Buckner,
who had been grants roommate at West Point.
There's a wonderful exchange of their dispatches that you can read if you want
to look it up,
easy to find grant rights to,
to uh,
Buckner and says,
hello friend,
I,
you will surrender all of your forces and all of your guns or I will move on.
You immediately.
And Buckner writes back and says,
well,
now,
wow,
now Ulysses can't.
Can we talk?
Grant writes back and says,
no.
And of course the press will pick this up.
You ask,
grant will become unconditional surrender grant.
The significance of Ford's Donaldson and Henry were not only symbolic because
the northern press pick this up waiting for war.
I mean,
got it.
Months and months and months had gone by since bull run,
there've been very few engagements.
The armies were growing all over the country.
Men were going off to war and writing letters home to their mothers,
sweethearts and families.
Here was some real war and some union victory.
Now hero,
most importantly,
strategically though the city of Nashville,
capital of Tennessee,
yeah.
Had to be abandoned by the confederates.
They could no longer defend it and they did abandoned.
It was partly a strategic retreat and partly out of the reality.
Then I'm the people to defend it.
Okay.
And a confederate army beginning to grow.
Now this into the spring of 1862 as thousands more southern boys and men with
leave those farms and hundreds of regiments from Mississippi,
Alabama,
Louisiana,
and Texas in particular.
They will come to join the army of Albert Sidney Johnston,
who led the confederate small confederate army out of Nashville,
down south,
westward into southwest Tennessee.
Just across the border to the town of Corinth,
Mississippi,
and it was around Corinth,
Mississippi in the North East tip corner of myth of the state of Mississippi
that a huge confederate army was assembled.
Now,
grant was now put in command of all union forces all over Tennessee.
Grant though,
had no idea really what the confederates were going to do and what happened at
the battle of Shiloh was not only the first major,
horrible bloody battle of the war and was shocked the country,
but it was a total surprise to the union forces.
Put simply,
here's what happened.
Albert,
Sidney Johnston had about 40,000 troops at Corinth.
Mississippi grant had at his disposal about 60,000 troops.
He's just still the size of the army that will begin to unfold in eastern
Virginia.
The grant had his army split in two
okay.
And and widely apart about one third of it was under the command of a general
named Don Carlos Buell,
and he was in central Tennessee.
Grants forces were sort of more western Tennessee and both were slowly trying to
move down toward south western Tennessee and maybe even into Mississippi.
To find this confederate army in March and early April of 62
what happened was it Albert Sidney Johnston attempted a surprise attack,
and it was one of the most successful surprise attacks by these large unwieldy
army is that ever happened in this war.
He marched his men 20,000 excuse me,
20 miles,
most of it in darkness with all kinds of clothing and burlap used as muffling on
the wheels of caissons and wagons.
Even men were told to put muffling on their boots and they marched through the
night in the dark,
April 5th to sixth 1862 north from Corinth cross the border into Tennessee and
they attacked our remnant sizable remnant of grants forces that had just reached
a place called Pittsburgh landing or Shiloh church,
as it's known,
it's a tiny little village.
Okay.
And what happened on the first day at Shiloh was the bloodiest day of the war
until that point in time,
grants troops were literally caught with their pants down.
They had no pickets out.
They had no idea where the confederate army really was,
nor specialist that they were that close.
There are many famous descriptions of this and soldiers letters and diaries and
afterward by Ambrose Bierce especially of how this sneak attack had caught them
literally around their tents in the morning making coffee,
some of them without their pants.
On.
The first day at Shiloh was a complete confederate victory.
It drove the union forces right back to the river,
the Tennessee river,
and by the time grant and one of his other generals,
William Tecumseh Sherman arrived that night.
They found remnants of this completely defeated union fourth hiding on the banks
of the Tennessee river.
Many of them having lost their regimens,
lost their command,
lost their officers,
didn't know where they were.
Through the dark of night,
April 6th to seventh it was a specialty Sherman and other officers as Don Carlos
Bules,
20,000 men arrived at in the middle of that night,
Sherman and other officers literally at times whipped union soldiers into order,
tried to help men find their units.
And when dawn came the next day,
they counter attacked across the same fields and savage hand to hand combat
that.
And all of these soldiers had never experienced and never seen.
And by the end of it,
they completely reversed the first day's action.
Battle of Shiloh took place in an area about a mile to a mile and a half in
diameter.
And by the end of the second day,
as grant famously put it in one of the very few moments in his two volume memoir
where he ever kind of really broke down and describe the current edge.
He said,
I could have walked across that field as far as the eye could see and never
touch the ground by walking on the bodies
for the two armies.
In 48 hours,
there were 23,841 casualties,
23,841 casualty.
No,
Shiloh strategically was,
this was a union success in the simple fact that,
you know,
the confederate army had to retreat
back into Mississippi and did not succeed in reentering Tennessee and opening up
a new front in Tennessee or taking control of the Tennessee river in that
region.
But it was truly a shock to the country when these casual dealers came back and
were published in newspapers and when they adjutants of regiments,
which was the job of an origin and a regimen was to record the casualties and
send them home.
Yeah.
And it was of course that site where grant remembered realizing for the first
time,
and I had that quote up here the other day and you can read it in gap where he
said it was at that moment I realized that this work could never be,
that the union could never be preserved without what he called complete conquest
of the south.
Okay.
That's what Bruce Catton men.
Wow.
The scabbard was being thrown away.
It was now a war where no one would ever call retreat.
Now back east,
back to the melodrama between um,
McClellan
and Lincoln.
Nope.
That's not the one,
excuse me.
I think you can see enough of this
now.
Mclellan throughout that winter kept training,
training and training the army of the Potomac,
and he did train them in to what any military store and still say it was one of
the most efficient and certainly the best supplied armies the world had ever
seen.
He would have almost a hundred thousand troops.
She'd have 90,000 in the field,
100,000 troops under his command,
and he came up with a plan that Lincoln hated Edmunds stand secretary of war.
It didn't like it.
Officers around him didn't particularly like it,
but it was Mcclellan's idea.
Mcallen did not want to invade Virginia from the north.
He thought it would be a better idea to sale the entire army of the Potomac,
down the Potomac river,
out into Chesapeake Bay and land on the peninsula between the York and the James
Rivers in Virginia
and invade Virginia toward Richmond.
The capitol of the confederacy take the enemy's capital,
was his aim here.
A strategy eventually that you to this grant is going to tear it to shreds and
quickly realized as he was realizing out in the West that the confederacy was
its armies,
not it's capital,
not a city here at town there the idea was to land,
this is huge,
full till of an army on the coast and March at 60 70 miles inland and attack
Richmond from the east.
Now part of the theory here it was that the confederacy had been fortifying the
north side of Richmond but maybe not the east side.
Now it's no surprise folks,
if you float 90,000 people down the river and land them on the coast and you,
you might be coming from the east,
what wouldn't be whole,
but this is where,
I mean I don't want to make Mcclellan into just comic relief like Burns does.
I think he overdoes it,
but here it is.
It is important to understand the generals did have impact on this war.
It was not that McClellan had a personal distaste for battle necessarily.
Those charges that he was somehow a coward and all that.
I don't think that holds up at all,
but he did not like huge general engagements and he did not want to sacrifice
any more men than he had to.
And remember,
he doesn't want the war to become remorseless.
Yeah,
he put the town of York town on the coast.
The same Yorktown were Cornwallis and surrender to George Washington,
the American revolution.
He Put York town under siege when he landed for an entire month from April 5th
to May 4th because McClellan was convinced that he was confronted with far more
men than he really was.
At one point,
Mcclellan actually wrote a dispatch,
the secretary of war Stanton,
claiming that he was facing on the peninsula at least 200,000 confederates.
There weren't 200,000 confederates,
underarms,
anywhere in the south in 1862 when McClellan was always overestimating his
enemy.
He hired the Pinkerton detectives.
He hired this guy named low with his balloons.
This was the first use of balloons and warfare.
They float these things up in the air and the gold and they'd float over the
enemy and they try to count the forces and they'd hope the wind was right,
the float them back and land them.
They were pretty cumbersome,
lawful thing.
Well,
you know,
one time the thing floated and it crashed and the other side of the confederate
troops,
he was getting his intelligence from all these new modern ways and every time he
got intelligence,
it's apparent that McAllen would just start doing some multiplication.
Oh,
there's so many stories about this.
I'll spare you.
He didn't need to put a dark,
dark town under siege for a month.
He could have taken it in 48 hours.
Kind of.
Confederates had built a lot of fortifications,
huge fortifications,
but didn't have very many men behind it,
and we're one officer might see one confederate and field glass.
Mcallen would see five or 10
given this caution,
given this slowness,
the confederate command in Richmond sent the young generals,
stonewall Jackson.
Yeah.
With about 20,000 men over to the Shenandoah valley here.
Okay.
Wow.
Mcclellan Atlanta,
this massive army on the peninsula was slowly beginning to move.
They sent stonewall Jackson with an Army of about 20,000 under the Shenandoah
valley where stonewall Jackson conducted one of the most famous military
campaigns in history,
and they still teach this and my new detail at West Point,
okay.
Actually only had about 17,000 men.
The purpose of this was to throw fear into northern Virginia,
fear into the Capitol in Washington and to keep about 30,000 union troops in
northern Virginia.
The McClellan had left behind.
The idea here was that McClellan would move from the East 30,000 roughly union
troops and moved from the north and they would crush rich Richmond from two
sides and the war would be over by July.
Confederates saw this and they said,
all right,
Jackson spent the period April 29 to June five five weeks roughly marching all
up and down the Shenandoah valley,
driving his men to utter exhaustion.
20 and 25 miles a day.
He fought five major battles march 400 miles in those five weeks for lots of
kind of contact rear guard actions.
It alluded three different union armies or parts of union armies at various
times through fear into Washington,
kept the 30,000 union troops all occupied in northern Virginia and western
Virginia and then escaped back down the valley and back to Richmond.
By the time McClellan attacked,
it wasn't extraordinary campaign.
It made stonewall Jackson's fame.
Now
the first major contact finally between the Union forces and confederate forces
on the peninsula came at a place called seven pines or five oaks.
It's a place about some six seven miles is the Richmond.
It would be the first major bloody affair for this army of the Potomac and I
want to describe it for you by simply reading excerpts from a few letters of a
union soldier leading up to the moment of his first major battle.
I want to do this in part because we need to understand,
and we'll come back to this question a bit later there.
What a common soldier out there in the field understands about what is happening
is of course almost always a blur.
It's the fog of war that he sees.
I had the opportunity about,
Oh God,
15 years ago now to edit a collection of civil war letters that were locked in
my lap.
A young soldier from Massachusetts and I'm Charles Brewster.
Charley Brewster was a store clerk in North Hampton,
Massachusetts.
One of the civil war broke out and they,
April of 61 he was 27 years old.
He felt like a total failure in life.
He was not yet married.
He had nothing going on and he enlisted as fast as he could and the 10th
Massachusetts and he spent that whole fall and winter of 61 62 in camp and I'm
will mentioned Charlie again next week because Charlie was,
no abolition is trust me,
but he comes to realize through this experience that the war has to destroy
slavery.
Interesting model of the average Yankee,
but he wrote incredible letters always to his mother or his sister.
He writes this on May 20th Battle Fair oaks or seven pines occurred on May 31st
of 1862 he knows a big battles coming.
They don't know exactly where or when it is raining like hell.
He's sleeping in the mud on what he calls a rubber blanket.
He gets diarrhea that nearly as killing him and he will almost die of diarrhea
twice in this war,
but he keeps writing to his mother and one morning the rain has stopped and he's
tells her what a beautiful morning it is.
Mother,
I wish you could see what a splendid morning this is.
The trees are in full foliage and the birds are singing in the trees and the
water ripples and sparks at my feet with the sun shining gloriously overall and
if were not for the regimen I see before me each with his deadly Enfield rifle
on his shoulder.
I could hardly imagine that there was a war anywhere in the land.
Now Day
by day he writes every day to his mother.
Long Letters.
I mean some of these letters hand written were 15 to 20 page letter and he wrote
about 240 of them in the course of the war.
May 22nd in a Cloverfield.
He says,
dear mother,
it is just sunset and most beautiful day though it has been dreadful hot.
How's relieved this morning from my grand do guard duty at general keys
headquarters joined the regimen and immediately took up my line of March with
them.
We came on about two miles or perhaps not quite as far as that and bivouacked in
this field,
which is the best place we have had since we left.
Warrick are small brigade is in the advance and we go out on picket frequently.
Yeah,
we do not know anything of what is going on in the world outside of our camp.
How I wish I could see a late paper.
We've got a rumor that there's been a battle out in Corinth,
Mississippi and at Bora garden.
23,000 men are prisoners,
but I presume there is no truth in it.
Artillery Tillery had a skirmish last night in a swamp and the front.
We're expecting a great battle mom,
but I reckon that little Mac will make his dispositions for it and the cavalry I
sorry,
and the chivalry,
which means to the south.
We'll take a distant view of his preparations and then skedaddle his usual.
If they don't,
they won't get a terrible looking though.
It is reported that they are concentrating everything there.
And I've got 140,000 troops
are contraband,
meaning an escaped slave that came in yesterday,
says that they are talking terrible,
fierce about burning Richmond,
fighting over the ashes.
But I think that's all Bosh
Thursday morning,
may 23
on picket,
he says,
dear mother,
captain and myself slept under the same blanket last night and on the ground in
front of the muskets and it was a harder and it was harder than Pharaoh's heart,
but it promotes early rising
for it's now 7:00 AM and I'd been up for three hours
in an old field Saturday may 24
okay.
I had the best view of the army in motion there that I ever had as they came
down a long slope of low hills to the creek and then up the other side.
And as we arrived at the top of the ladder slope,
I turned and took a look back and could see the long line looking like an
enormous snake winding back for two and three miles and bristling with bayonets
and at a short distance the stars and Stripes and the flags at different states
and the Guido's presenting a scene that occurs.
But once in a great while it is raining like great guns again and the order has
come to pack up and move on.
Okay.
Oh dear mother,
this is the next day a large male has come and everybody has got something but
me,
I cannot write anymore under such circumstances.
So goodbye my love to all.
And if you can any of you spare time,
please write me a letter.
Love Charlie Wednesday,
May 28th dear mother,
today the sun shines brightly and it is brazen hot,
but at half past two this company has got to go out and digging the trenches for
two hours.
One thing is very certain,
if they do not take Richmond soon,
it will kill the whole army by this ceaseless exposure and toil.
May 31st the day of the battle of seven pines
mother.
And now in relation to the coming battle,
if anything should happen and I should get killed,
you will be entitled to my pay.
There is three months,
do me
okay,
but if I should get not get paid off before anything should happen,
my pay will be in two places.
That is from the march,
from the march,
meaning the month there will be $50 per month in the state treasury,
Massachusetts,
which I have a lot of their subject to my own order.
The rest of my pay is drawn from the u s paymaster as usual.
Imagine being his mother.
Okay.
And then this is letter after the battle.
June two 1862 six miles from Richmond.
Dear mother,
I presume this letter will find you most anxious expecting a letter from me.
I'm sitting in the hot sun and can write you but a few lines.
Oh mother,
I cannot begin to give you any idea of the terrific storm of bullets shot and
show that poured over us as we lay behind those pits.
We could not get into them for,
they were full of brime of water,
but we lay right behind them in the mud.
After half an hour of this,
the firing ceased and we were ordering forward behind some fallen woods.
And then he goes on to describe how they were attack from the rear
and how he heard the bullets flying by him constantly and how he considers it a
miracle that he is alive.
And then at the very end of this letter,
I cannot succeed in giving you any idea of battle,
but I know this much that I had no possible hope of coming out alive and I
thought it all over how terribly you would feel and all that.
But it came out without a scratch.
I look back upon it and I cannot think how it can be.
It does not seem as though any man that had been there could come out unhurt
then he begins to describe his friends and buddies who were killed by name,
how they were killed,
where they were shot.
And Yens,
there are so many incidents crowding my head mother,
I cannot write clearly at all.
And even when I sleep,
the minute I get into a dose,
I hear the whistling of the shows and the shouts and the groans,
and to sum it up in two words,
it is
horrible.
Charlie will survive the war.
He nearly died of dysentery twice.
He had two horses shut out from under him.
He was deeply proud of his commission as a second lieutenant is an adjutant of
his regimen,
his regimen with a devastated.
There were so few men left by July of 1864 they were disbanded.
He went home to Massachusetts.
He couldn't imagine a civilian.
He
hated the civilians.
He reenlisted to be a recruiter of black soldiers.
This racist young man from western Massachusetts who freely use the word nigger,
was employed from August of 1864 through the end of the war recruiting black men
in Norfolk,
Virginia,
and his principle job was sitting in an office writing love letters for
illiterate black women to their husbands at the front
whom he,
thanks for teaching him the art of love letter writing.
Yeah,
well the battle of the peninsula ended up in what's called the seven days.
The Battle of the seven days,
uh,
or the battles fought all around Richmond from June 25th through July 1st six
consecutive seven consecutive days,
places called Mechanicsville gains mills savage station,
Frazier's farm,
Malverne Hill.
They're all little crossroads.
They're not even really villages anymore that are just east of Richmond.
Okay.
It was sustained day to day fighting.
Both sides suffered horrible casualties.
The result was essentially the fact that Mcclellan did not succeed in taking
Richmond.
In fact,
on the contrary,
McCallen's forces were forced down south of Richmond to the edge of the James
River to a place called Malverne hill
where McClellan put his wounded damaged army into camp for too long.
Okay?
The Battle of the seven days saved Richmond.
It's saved the confederacy.
It also brought Robert E.
Lee into the command of the Union of all confederate forces in the eastern
theater of the war because,
uh,
Joseph [inaudible] Johnston,
who had been in command of the confederate forces,
was wounded on the first day of the seven days.
And Jefferson Davis put Leonne Command.
And it was in some ways Lee's aggressiveness and the seven days that actually
one that a fair
and now lean made the first fateful decision of the war for him.
After many consultations with Jefferson Davis and his other commanders,
he made the decision to invade the North
and this was faithful to say the least and it will bring us to the first major
turning point of the civil war.
I've just run the clock out.
I fear,
oh,
I have two minutes.
Let me leave you here.
The idea Lee had,
and it's not that complicated,
is that the war was not devastating.
Virginia Richmond was all but under siege.
The theory here was take the war to the north,
take the war out of Virginia,
take the war to northern soil,
hopefully get into Maryland,
and he believed there were thousands of Maryland men who would come to the
confederate standard if they saw the confederate army threaten the capitol.
Washington d C threatened Philadelphia in Pennsylvania,
threatened the north,
take the word of their soil to their farms or their homes,
and strategically,
and this was the word Jefferson Davis agreed with him all that he was a very
leery about this,
a strike into the north that could win a major victory on northern soil and
threatened the union capital,
possibly even threatened.
Even fourth and evacuation of the federal capitol might bring the most important
thing the confederacy needed,
and they were on the verge of it,
and that was British intervention,
British recognition and intervention on the side of the confederacy.
I'll discuss that possible intervention more as a piece of how emancipation
becomes the result of this Antietam campaign next week.
But let me leave you here.
Okay.
Lead decides in the face of a kind of queen essence McClellan
to leave only a small force in Richmond
and move north into Virginia and invade the North Mcclellan's army.
Having suffered 20,000 casualties in the seven days is not going to move
and he's not going to move until he absolutely has to.
It is the first great daring move of the war.
It will fail,
but it nearly succeeded.
And the reason to Antidem is the first major turning point of this war is not
just because of the decisive battle they fought on the Maryland side of the
Potomac,
but because it will be the occasion to all our Abraham Lincoln to do what he'd
been planning to do through much of that summer.
And Congress had been prodding him to do,
which was to announce to the world that this was a war to free the slaves.
See you next week.